قال وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني ديمترو
كوليبا في مقابله مع الجزيره مصره على
خروج اخر جندي روسيا واستعاده كل الاراضي
واكد ان علاقات بلاده مع الولايات المتحده
مبنيه على الثقه مضيفا انهم يسعون لتحويل
مشكله تسريب الوثائق الى فرصه لتسريع
الحصول على الاسلحه المطلوبه واضاف كوليبا
ان توقيت الهجوم المضاد يتاثر طرديا بسرعه
وصول الدعم الى اوكرانيا داعيا من وصفها
بالدول الصديقه الى مساعده بلاده في تحقيق
اهدافها
على الفشل والحياه لم تعلمه اي درس لذا
فهو مستمر بالفشل اوكرانيا لديها القدره
على الانتصار في الحرب واستعاده وحده
اراضيها ادعو الدول الصديقه التي التزمت
الحياد ان تساعد اوكرانيا في تحقيق
اهدافها بدلا من التفكير بخيارات اخرى
الاطراف التي تشكك بقدره اوكرانيا على
الانتصار في الحرب هي نفس الاطراف التي
اعتقدت ان اوكرانيا لن تصمد اكثر من عشره
ايام اذا غزتها روسيا
وشدد كوليبا على ان اي خطه سلام يرغب اي
طرف في طرحها ينبغي ان ترتكز على مبدا
اساسي واحترام وحده اراضي اوكرانيا ضمن
حدودها المعترف بها دوليا واشار كوليبا
الى ان اي خطه سلام تتضمن تنازل بلاده عن
اراضي لها هي امر خاطئ سياسيا وقانونيا
واخلاقيا على حد تعبيره
اي خطه سلام تهدف الى استعاده وحده
الاراضي الاوكرانيه هي جيده وهي خطه سلام
تتضمن تنازل اوكرانيا عن اراضي لها
والتجميد الصراع تعتبر سيئه اوكرانيا
لديها خطه سلام شامله مفصله اسمها صيغه
السلام التي طرحها
ونعتقد انها الطريق الامثل لانهاء هذا
الصراع وحل كل القضايا التي نتجت عنه